des donneurs de sang au théâtre face aux
flux de donneurs la collecte prend ses
quartiers au théâtre national de saint
quentin en yvelines
il ya beaucoup plus d'espacé et puis je
pense aussi que ça change beaucoup de
choses pour pour les personnes qui
travaillent ici qui sont dans des
conditions qu'on est là mon sens plus
puis confortable du moment qu'on est
entouré par un staff compétent quelqu'un
a donc on peut faire ça en confiance
sans aucun problème huit personnes de
l'établissement français du sang telles
que lille et dont contribution à
l'entr'aide civisme c'est ce qui motive
les donneurs je sais qu'il ya un besoin
et que voilà c'est pas c'est un petit
peu de temps c'est pas faim voilà c'est
un peu de sens et ça peut servir à
beaucoup d'autres personnes donc c'est
pour ça que j'essaie de venir assez
régulièrement pour nous c'est une
période un peu critique ou en tout cas
où on est très attentifs pendant les
vacances les franciliens partent la
plupart or or hors de paris hors de
l'ile-de-france et ceux qui sont reste
ils ont d'autres choses à penser que de
donner du sang par contre les malades
eux ils sont toujours présents
les collectes de sang vont se poursuivre
d'ici à la fin de l'année le théâtre
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
accueillera cinq autres collectes